the sun's magnetic field is crucial to
our solar system the planets circling
our Sun are swaddled in a Sun generated
bubble called the heliosphere closer in
the Sun bombards earth with a powerful
stream of charged particles called the
solar wind and these particles can
affect orbiting satellites and the
planets electrical grid telescopes like
the Solar Dynamics Observatory are
sharpening our picture of the sun's
outer atmosphere known as the solar
corona it's the changing magnetic field
in the corona that causes solar flares
and eruptions which hurl balls of plasma
out into interplanetary space the
strings of plasma that you see here are
called coronal loops they're bright and
easy to observe so they can be used to
trace some of the Coronas magnetic field
lines but further out plasma emission
becomes dim and more diffuse and because
spacecraft can't fly in close enough to
directly measure it the large-scale
structure of the coronal magnetic field
largely remains a mystery
so this reason scientists were excited
when Comet Lovejoy approached the Sun in
December 2011
Lovejoy belongs to the Kreutz family of
comments often called Sungrazers because
they periodically fly into the Sun and
fizzle out in its atmosphere but Lovejoy
was so big roughly 200 to 500 meters in
diameter that it was able to survive the
Sun's corona and fly right out through
the opposite side at its closest it
passed within 140,000 kilometers of the
sun's surface web Troy was recorded by a
number of telescopes including NASA's
Solar Dynamics Observatory and twins
stereo spacecraft as we watch the comet
approach the Sun we noticed something
bizarre its tail wiggled and rapidly
changed direction it didn't follow the
predictable curve that most tails do and
we wondered why a comet's tail is
essentially a trail of vaporized ions so
we hypothesized that the Wiggles we
observed were the result of interactions
between these ions and the sun's
magnetic field
then using a state-of-the-art computer
model of the sun's corona we connected
the motion of the tail directly to
magnetic field lines showing that
Lovejoy was in fact probing the
invisible magnetic field of the solar
corona here you can see the magnetic
field lines we use to extrapolate the
motions of the comet's tail blue lines
are closed loops and orange lines extend
out into space
following Lovejoy has proven invaluable
for physicists the comet provided an
opportunity to probe an area that our
own spacecraft can't reach and it did it
in a new way one that's complementary to
other methods like imaging the Sun's
corona at varying wavelengths of light
we look forward to the next Sun grazing
comet
because the more we know about the solar
corona the better equipped will be to
interpret the sun's activity and even
predict how it will affect the earth